During the shutdown, I had extra time to read.
Here are five books that I highly recommend.
The Choice by Dr. Edith Eger.
It's a hell of a story.
The woman was a 16-year-old girl in Auschwitz.
She eventually does survive,...
...gets out and moves to Texas,...
...and becomes this inspirational therapist,...
...and half of the book is her story.
Half of it is how she helps other people.
Cloud Atlas by David Mitchell.
It such an unusual book and it's clever.
You go through six different epics in history...
...where you have people making moral choices,...
...where you see how self-centered and bad people can be,...
...and how supportive and good people can be.
You really do feel he captures these different worlds.
The Ride of a Lifetime by Bob Iger.
It's hard to overstate how demoralized and messed up Disney was.
Things weren't in great shape when they got rid of Eisner.
And I do consider it brilliant of Iger...
...that in an age where networks are not important,...
...and you're going to have to go direct to consumer,...
...that you've got to have a critical mass of the greatest content.
The Great Influenza by John Barry.
He explains how infections work and how the immune system works.
The 1918 Spanish Flu is the first world epidemic...
...where it basically hits the entire world at the same time.
Good Economics for Hard Times by Abhijit Banerjee and Esther Duflo.
This is the most important book of the group...
...because it really is about what do we know in the field of economics...
...that can take the current divisions and try and do better.
I found all these books really interesting,...
...and I hope you do also.